[Musica]
Io vorrei partire con una domanda Vorrei
sapere chi di voi sta studiando o fai il
lavoro che sognava di fare quando era
bambino Ecco io per esempio non sono tra
queste persone perché sono sempre stata
un po' confusa e ho cambiato idea
diverse volte per esempio quando avevo 5
anni mi immaginavo così perché mi
piaceva l'odore della benzina poi dopo
optyper diventare pediatra finché non ho
scoperto le siringhe e ho deciso che non
faceva per me a 9 anni Allora visto che
volevo viaggiare mi piaceva scrivere
decisi che l'opzione migliore sarebbe
stata diventare un'inviata speciale ma
il 7 ottobre del 2001 il giorno del mio
compleanno Buscio annunciò che avrebbe
invaso l'Afghanistan e gli unici inviati
speciali che vedeva quel tempo erano
sotto le bombe non mi sentivo così
coraggiosa Allora dopo mi iniziai ad
interessare un po' la carriera
diplomatica e avrei voluto lavorare alle
nazioni unite Ma non in
un'organizzazione qualsiasi ma il
quartiere generale di New York e vedete
che qui non abbiamo nessun fotomontaggio
perché sono andata Ma poi insomma è
durato poco
Allora quando ho finito il liceo Insomma
ero un po' confusa Non sapevo bene che
fare ho deciso di fare L'unica cosa che
proprio non mi piaceva mi sono iscritta
ad Economia e mi sono iscritta ad
Economia un po' perché volevo andare via
perché era una cosa che avevo sempre
detto che volevo andare al nord Questa
città mi stava stretta è stato un
fallimento dopo quattro mesi ho fatto le
valigie e sono tornata a casa ed è stato
difficile perché avevo perso un anno di
università e Perché i miei genitori per
rientrare dei soldi che li avevo fatto
letteralmente buttare alla Bocconi mi
hanno tagliato i viveri e sono andata a
lavorare
così quando a settembre ho dovuto di
nuovo decidere dove iscrivermi ho
pensato di seguire le mie passioni e di
non pensare alla fama dell'università
quindi mi sono iscritta all'unica
facoltà dove di solito vi dicono di non
andare Sapete qual è Scienze Politiche
Allora per tre anni la domanda che mi è
stata fatta più frequentemente è stata
vuoi rimanere disoccupata è chiaro non
volevo rimanere disoccupata quindi in
qualche modo Qualcosa dovevo combinarla
è un giorno a Roma ho incontrato un
Ambasciatore e ho pensato che era
un'occasione perfetta Allora mi sono
avvicinata e gli ho chiesto dei consigli
e lui piuttosto che chiedermi quali
fossero le mie aspirazioni le mie
passioni i miei interessi mi domanda se
un giorno avrei voluto avere una
famiglia io a quel tempo c' avevo 21
anni quindi insomma non è una priorità
di noi ragazze 21 anni una famiglia e
diciamo che nella società in cui viviamo
anche adesso è difficile che sia una
priorità però gli dissi di sì e lui
allora mi tutte le cose che quella
strada non faceva per me Ecco questo è
stato uno di quegli incontri che in
qualche modo mi hanno segnata e che non
so se sono stata fortunata o sfortunata
a farlo ma in me dopo aver parlato con
lui e c'era tanta rabbia perché avevo
capito che come donna non avevo le
stesse opportunità di un uomo e io
volevo essere certa che i miei diritti
fossero gli stessi di quelli di un uomo
che la mia possibilità di svilupparmi a
livello professionale fosse la stessa di
quella di svilupparmi a livello
personale Immagino che anche voi ragazzi
siete arrabbiati quando oggi sentite
dire che siete svogliati che siete
viziati perché non accettate lavori in
cui vi pagano uno stipendio misero e per
le ore di lavoro che non sono
minimamente giuste e non è vero chi vi
dice che la normalità e che dovreste
ringraziare Dio perché un lavoro ce
l'avete perché non è giusto perché non
sono questi diritti come il diritto allo
studio non è più garantito se per andare
all'università febbraio devo pagare 800
euro una stanza per poter studiare e
come io volevo essere certa che potessi
esser libera del mio corpo di amare chi
volevo di credere in quello che volevo
di dire liberamente quello che volevo e
pensavo che tutto questo non fosse
garantito quindi mi sono iniziata a
guardare intorno e ho trovato la
risposta a tutte queste mie esigenze
nell'Europa ed incontrare l'Europa non è
semplice perché spesso Siamo impreparati
a questo incontro Però tutti noi
l'estate Andiamo a mare giusto andiamo a
fare le vacanze e magari succede che un
anno al mare incontriamo quel ragazzo
straniero che viene qua perché c'è il
sole il mare si mangia bene e noi un po'
ci interessa ci incuriosisce però non
sappiamo bene come parla come comunicare
perché parliamo a due lingue diverse
abbiamo abitudini diverse lui ce ne alle
6 non alle 10 come Qua al Sud però in
qualche modo troviamo quel modo per
comunicare troviamo la chiave per
imparare a conoscerci dialogare e anche
se poi lui riparte perché le vacanze
finiscono ormai sappiamo come
relazionarci Ecco conoscere L'Europa è
simile e io vi capisco se voi pensate
che ogni tanto l'Europa sia distante
Perché anche io ho avuto questa
impressione perché avrei voluto che mi
insegnanti a scuola mi avessero parlato
di più di come funziona l'Unione Europea
che mi avessero spiegato meglio
l'attualità però questo spesso non
succede quindi voi non dovete aver paura
di chiedere o di informarvi perché non è
scontato che queste cose vi verranno
dette e quello che io ho capito vivendo
a Bruxelles e che non è importante
vivere a Bruxelles o lavorare nelle
istituzioni per conoscere e poter
interagire con l'Europa ma lo possiamo
fare tutti perché L'Europa è la nostra
città dobbiamo intenderla così quindi io
oggi vorrei riflettere su di voi su
questi dati Questo è un sondaggio che è
stato pubblicato dalla Commissione
Europea qualche anno qualche mese fa
scusate e come potete vedere il 44% dei
cittadini italiani hanno una visione
positiva dell'Unione Europea ma se io vi
faccio vedere questa slide di un
sondaggio condotto qualche anno fa
vediamo che nel periodo di novembre
dicembre 2020 la percezione positiva
dell'Unione Europea era molto più alta
era quasi al 63% per i cittadini
italiani il 72% per quelli europei e
come è possibile che in questo poco
tempo sia cambiata così tanto perché
l'Unione Europea è sempre la stessa
perché in quel periodo Noi abbiamo
vissuto una pandemia senza precedenti a
cui non eravamo preparati ed è vero che
l'Unione Europea ha assunto dei poteri
straordinari perché quella che è una
competenza statale come la sanità è
stata appunto inglobata dall'Europa E
perché Perché L'Unione Europea ha
acquistato dei vaccini e li ha
distribuiti in maniera equa tra tutti
gli stati per evitare che tra di noi ci
facessimo guerra entrassimo in
competizione come il successo Durante la
Seconda Guerra Mondiale Quindi che ci
fosse una specie di corsa al riarmo ma
non solo l'Unione Europea anche
acquistato dei vaccini per i paesi
extraeuropei come l'Africa perché in
quel periodo eravamo consapevoli che
nessuno sarebbe stato al sicuro se non
lo fossimo stati tutti
Quindi com'è possibile che la nostra
idea di Europa è cambiata così tanto e
io mi chiedo come è possibile perché
quando io vengo qui racconto un po'
quello che faccio alcune persone mi
dicono l'Europa fa schifo allora io mi
chiedo ma noi sappiamo davvero come
funziona l'Europa e cosa fa l'Europa per
noi per dire che l'Europa fa schifo
allora facciamo finta che queste verdure
che voi vedete qua dietro siano gli
stati membri ok Quindi questi stati così
come li vedete sono tutti separati sono
un po' insipidi nessuno vuole mangiare
il cavolfiore il sedano così quindi noi
vogliamo creare qualcosa di più buono di
migliore ed è quello che è successo qui
l'Unione Europea con questi stati e con
queste verdure noi possiamo fare per
esempio un'insalata russa che visto che
siamo in tema vorrei rassicurarvi è
stata inventata in Europa e non in
Russia
come vedete gli stati sono abbastanza
distinguibili perché noi possiamo vedere
tutte le verdure però stanno insieme e
stanno insieme perché c'è Un collante
questo collante è la maionese quindi noi
dobbiamo far finta che la maionese sia
l'Unione Europea che ci tiene tutti
insieme per fare la maionese abbiamo
bisogno delle uova dell'olio e del
limone quindi facciamo finta che le uova
sono la Commissione Europea l'olio e il
Parlamento Europeo è la commissione il
Consiglio Europeo Queste sono le tre
istituzioni principali dell'Unione
Europea Allora la Commissione Europea è
presieduta da Ursula van der Lion e
dell'organo esecutivo dell'Europa quindi
per intenderci il nostro governo ha
iniziativa legislativa quindi che vuol
dire che propone una legislazione sulla
base di quelle che sono le priorità dei
cittadini e questa proposta passa il
Parlamento adesso il Parlamento Io sono
un po' di parte direi che l'organo più
importante ma perché rappresentano i
cittadini
e la nostra voce perché siamo noi che
leggiamo direttamente i 705 membri del
Parlamento Europeo ogni 5 anni La
presidente Roberta Mezzola quindi che
succede che
arriva la proposta della commissione la
modifica e la vota ma per diventare
legge questa proposta deve essere votata
e approvata allo stesso modo anche dal
Consiglio il Consiglio Europeo è
preceduto da Sharm el Sheila ed è
composto dai capi di stato e di governo
quindi per intenderci il Presidente del
Consiglio dei Ministri in questo momento
la meloni Ok Che cosa succede succede
che se il Parlamento e il consiglio non
sono d'accordo sulla stessa proposta
cade e rischi di avere ricominciare
tutto da capo ma su alcune su alcune
aree come per esempio la politica estera
che sono delle aree un po' sensibili il
consiglio Quindi gli stati devono votare
all'unanimità che succede che se anche
un solo stato vota in maniera contraria
e poi nel vetro
Dobbiamo di nuovo ricominciare da capo e
in questo ambito per esempio rientra uno
dei temi caldi quale Quello della
migrazione quindi Voi capite bene che
una democrazia che deve funzionare ad
unanimità non funziona ma quale stato
secondo voi è disposto a cedere parte
dei suoi poteri in quelle che sono delle
aree strategiche ad un ente
sovranazionale perdendo quindi potere
molto pochi quello che io vi voglio dire
ragazzi è che l'Unione Europea non è
perfetta L'Unione Europea ha dei limiti
però come ogni relazione è fatta da due
persone queste due persone devono
interagire e l'Unione Europea crede
soprattutto nei giovani e le sue
cittadine perché grazie a noi che può
andare avanti e può andare avanti nelle
legislazioni in quelle che sono le
proposte per migliorare la nostra vita
quindi che vuol dire che l'Unione
Europea non è perfetta Deve cambiare ma
come possiamo cambiare qualcosa che non
conosciamo non possiamo quindi diciamo
che c'è una regola delle Tre C cioè
conoscere essere consapevoli e
contribuire se noi non conosciamo tutto
quello che abbiamo intorno non possiamo
partecipare e io mi rivolgo soprattutto
a voi ragazzi perché l'Unione Europea
mette veramente tanti progetti e
programmi a disposizione di voi giovani
dandovi i fondi contributi come il
programma Horizon per la ricerca che uno
dei più grossi esistenti al mondo o
grazie alle piattaforme che vi
permettono di incontrare altri giovani
come voi che hanno le stesse idee le
stesse ambizioni e gli stessi progetti
li fa viaggiare vi fa scoprire il mondo
altre culture o per esempio Chi di voi
ha sentito parlare o ha partecipato alla
conferenza sul futuro dell'Europa
questa conferenza è stata lanciata due
anni fa ed è stato uno dei più grandi
esperimenti di democrazia partecipativa
degli ultimi anni e che ha coinvolto i
cittadini tutti e le organizzazioni
delle società civile per formulare delle
raccomandazioni su quelle che sono delle
priorità per noi cittadini e alle quali
poi le istituzioni dovranno dare seguito
dobbiamo essere consapevoli perché
ragazzi Noi pensiamo che il mondo in cui
viviamo sia dato per sempre perché noi
siamo nati e siamo già nati cittadini
europei ma questo prima non era così
perché noi viviamo in un continente di
pace ma vediamo i nostri confini che la
guerra esiste può arrivare noi pensiamo
che la democrazia sia data per sempre ma
questo non è certo perché abbiamo visto
nel 2021 con l'attacco a capito lill che
ci può essere ci possono essere degli
assalti alla democrazia questo è
successo nella casa della democrazia
negli Stati Uniti ed è successo di nuovo
a planalto in Brasile oppure noi
possiamo prendere un treno e viaggiare
senza aver bisogno di avere il
passaporto possiamo viaggiare
semplicemente con la nostra carta
d'identità dall'Italia possiamo arrivare
alla Francia il Portogallo in Ungheria e
questo è Grazie all'Unione Europea o se
siamo in Spagna possiamo telefonare ai
nostri amici senza pagare tariffe
aggiuntive se siamo in Croazia possiamo
connetterci ad internet senza bisogno
di avere un piano dati diverso abbiamo
una moneta unica possiamo pagare con la
stessa moneta ovunque anche se
all'inizio l'euro proprio non ci piaceva
e facevamo le conversioni Io per esempio
a Bruxelles posso comprare i biscotti
alla Mulino Bianco come se fosse al
supermercato in Italia
ho ancora chi di voi ragazzi è già
andato o l'anno prossimo andrà in
Erasmus Voi sapete che il Parlamento
Europeo si è battuto affinché uno dei
programmi chiave della crescita dei
giovani non avesse i fondi tagliati o se
pensiamo a quello che è successo la
settimana scorsa in Emilia Romagna
l'Unione Europea mette a disposizione
degli Stati il Fondo di Solidarietà
europeo che un fondo che presta soccorso
immediato a tutti gli stati colpiti da
calamità naturale e l'Italia Per esempio
è uno dei maggiori beneficiari Dobbiamo
contribuire perché L'Unione Europea ha
bisogno delle nostre idee ha bisogno di
noi giovani e questo è chiaro perché per
esempio il Next Generation you che è il
piano Marshall europeo Diciamo che è
stato varato dopo il covid si chiama
next generation you perché punta sulle
prossime generazioni punta sui giovani
oppure quando voi vi dicono che che
siete gli ultimi ragazzi della catena
della società che non contate niente che
tanto non dovete protestare perché le
vostre idee non vengono ascoltate Non è
vero perché i Green Village il patto
verde dell'Unione Europea e uno dei
piani più ambiziosi per il cambiamento
climatico al mondo e perché è iniziato
tutto perché i giovani come voi sono
scesi in strada a protestare con fridays
for future quelli che cosa vuol dire che
l'Unione Europea non è perfetta e deve
cambiare Come già cambiata prima era una
comunità di sei stati è diventato
un'unione di 27 e probabilmente con i
prossimi allargamenti arriveremo a 35
perché ogni Stato capisce la convenienza
di far parte dell'Unione Europea ogni
Stato sa che le sfide future e le sfide
future sono globali e che possiamo
affrontarle solo insieme comunione
quindi dobbiamo cambiare ma dobbiamo
anche trovare il coraggio di partecipare
ci sono due cose che dobbiamo tenere in
mente visione perché dobbiamo essere
lungimiranti in modo tale da non
lasciare un pianeta malato alle future
generazioni o un mondo pieno di debiti
come quello che ci hanno lasciato i
nostri genitori ma dobbiamo anche avere
memoria perché se noi non sappiamo Da
dove veniamo non sappiamo dove stiamo
andando Quando è stato eletto come
Presidente del Parlamento Europeo David
Sassoli ha detto che noi non siamo un
incidente della storia non solo io credo
che non sia un incidente la storia ma io
credo che l'Europa sia il nostro destino
e noi giovani siamo il futuro e il
presente di questo continente Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]